[Music]
so so far you can see how dangerous this
gambit is if black accepted
but
if your opponent declined it
does it has the same venom
well as i have highlighted over here
black has three ways to decline this
gambit
and let's see each by turn to find out
what we are up to
the first move i want to consider is the
most popular one
namely knight to c6
and after this all you have to remember
is
take on c5
so that when black recapture
we can once again build up our nice pawn
chain
with d4 attacking the bishop
and this bishop has two good locations
i particularly do not like the move
bishop to e7 because then black is
really struggling to get the g8 knight
out
so the first move bishop to b6
i think now you get hang of this gambit
right
the next move of white is very obvious
c3
creating a wonderful pawn chain
and after knight g to e7
the golden move you remember
yup
bishop to d3
completely stopping blank to castle on
the king's side
well apart from castle black has other
moves so for example if we continue with
knight to g6 then as we seen in the
accept variation
we have the move h4 h5
and if he plays knight to f5
then later on we can always kick this
knight with g4
the big remarkable difference here is
black bishop has been sidelined so our
dark square bishop can goes to a3 and
control
all these dark squares
but let's roll back to a critical
question
why can't black castle here what is the
problem
and the answer is very obvious
if you have seen my chess trap 2 greek
gift
then i am sure you instantly spot
this dazzling sacrifice on at 7.
yup bishop takes at 7.
if white doesn't take it then he is a
clear pawn down
so most of the player has taken this
but after this
the follow up is very easy one
knight to g5 check
black king has two options
but amongst them king to g8 is the worst
one
because after this
you play the simplest move in the world
queen to h5
looking at the juicy h7 square
and the only route to escape this king
is by playing rook to e8
completely fails here
because of the following deadly sequence
queen to h7 king to f8
and now the star move
bishop to a3 pinning down the e79
so that in the next move queen to h8
leads to checkmate
so you can see how quickly game can be
finished
if black goes to g8 square
the more critical option is king to g6
but after this
i propose this very strong move h4
and the idea is very obvious
regardless of black plays we are going
to continue with h5 and
nabbing the black queen
so let me show you a sample line by far
the most popular choice here is
f5
but this is already a disaster zone
because after h5 king has only square
available namely at 6
and after this
yup
knight to e6
discover check and nabbing the black
sweetie
so now let's check out what we are going
to do against bishop to b4 check
and yet again the answer is very simple
c3
bishop to e5 and now golden move bishop
to d3
okay
we have knight g to e7
and because black hasn't castle
i propose this
very crafty move a4
a constructive waiting moon
so that if
black castle here foolishly
then we have this greek gift
as we seen just earlier
so that's a bad idea by black camp
if knight to g6 then we have h4 h5
so that means the only good option here
is knight to f5
which at first sight looks very good
move because black is attacking over d4
but you know what
we are going to play bishop to e3
pretending that we have not seen the
thread
and telling your opponent
okay buddy go ahead take that pawn
well i bet very few black players will
resist this
so the obvious continuation here is
knight captures d4
but this is a huge mistake because of
the following forcing variation
knight catches d4
knight captures d4
now we play queen to g4 a double attack
so black response is forced he has to
play knight to f5
and as this knight is the only defender
of g7 the task of white is very easy
you chop up this knight and then after
you take on g7
[Music]
well not so surprising
black get a completely losing cave
his rook has no way to go
and in order to protect this rook
black has to play this ugly move
king to d7
whereupon white has this straight away
winning sequence
e6 jack
if king takes then castle is a very
strong reply
so king to c6 is the best reply here
but after that
simple move
e captures f7 and sooner or later
this pawn will promote to queen
and look at the pathetic position of the
black king
clearly the game shouldn't be last long
so guys these are some of the wonderful
tricks exist if you open and continue
with knight to c6
declining the gambit
finally let's check out the two other
way to decline this variation and the
first one is
b6
keeping the black structure flexible
and maybe black has an idea of bishop to
a6
so against this my recommendation is you
start with c3
stopping bishop to e6 because
if black played then this is a blunder
guys
as after bishop takes knight takes and
queen check
we are nabbing the piece
so that is right out of the equation
and apart from this
no matter whatever black plays white
simple idea is
he wants to play a3 and d4
and thus
getting our good center
so let me show you a sample line
knight to c6 has been highestly played
here
we continue with a3
and doesn't matter whatever black plays
let's say knight g to e7
we continue with d4
the point is after c captures d4 and the
move c captures d4
we again obtain the wonderful center
and our plan will remain the same
there are some nasty tricks if your
opponent continue with knight to f5
which is in fact
the most preferred choice by the black
camp
and against this you can start either
with knight c3 or h4
let's say in this game white plays h4
first
and after bishop to e7 he continued with
knight to c3
which indeed sets up the platform
for the cunning tricks
there are two moves which are outright
bad here
number one knight captures h4 mistake
we already seen this right
knight takes bishop takes and now queen
to g4
creating a double attack followed up
with
knight to b5 and knight to d6 jack
which pick up the rook on the king's
side
okay
what about the other choice
namely castle on the king's side
well this time around white can play
another attacking jab
g4
knight cap snatch 4 is a forced
but
after knight takes bishop takes and the
move b5
sadly black knight cannot go to the king
side and wherever it goes on the queen
side let's say knight to a5
we have the star move
g5
the same old tactic
bishop g5
queen h5
at 6
and this time around
we have a tactical blow from the
different angle
f4
bishop to e7
and f5
completely dominating black on the
king's side
the threat is very obvious bishop at 6
and then mate on h file
so in order to avoid this black has to
play bishop to g5
whereupon
white plays the obvious move f6
shutting down the door
so that after bishop takes and rook
takes
you can try by yourself
black simply cannot avoid the checkmate
last but not least what to do against
the move
c4
well i propose this straightforward
approach you continue with c3 first
and black's idea is he wants to destroy
our pawn chain
by this a5 lever
but by doing this i reckon he is hurting
his position
as
we can continue with
b5
stopping the natural development of
black knight
and if allowed our simple plan is we
want to play a4 followed up with d3
which completely destroy
the black center
so by far as per the database the most
popular choice is
a4
stopping our a pawn advancement
but it does not stop our second break
namely
d3
after pawn takes and bishop takes
as you can see i have highlighted by the
arrows
simple but effective plan of campaign by
the white camp is
he wants to play queen to e2 castle and
then later on
timely pushed the move c4 which gave him
a very good game
let me show you how we can achieve this
by showing one of my recent game against
a 2100 rated opponent
here my opponent plays knight to d7
i responded with queen to e2
and after knight to c5
there is no way in the world i am going
to give this bishop
so i played bishop to c2
after bishop to d7
castle
i am all set to play the move c4
so my opponent rightly pressurized the
b-pawn with queen to b6
but as it turns out that this move is a
great disaster
because after c4
pawn takes and now knight to a3
and suddenly you can realize the danger
what really white is aiming is he wants
to take the c4 with the knight
and then jump on the juicy d6 square
well the game finished very quickly
he played bishop to e7
i took on c4 and when
my opponent finally take on b5
i give him this root shock rook to be
one attacking the queen
queen to c6
look at the bad king side development
which really hurting the black camp
rook to d1 has been played
f6
big mistake
knight to b6 attacking the rogue
rook to a6 counter-attacking
but missing the important tactic
knight to d7 knight captures d7 and now
sting in the tail
bishop to e4
p7 is a complete goner
and in fact in the game my opponent
plays queen to c7
which allow me to finish the game
instantly
with rook captures b7
and you can see the multiple pcs are
hanging as simply black cannot save his
rook as well as
knight on the d7
so i think this model game
gives you a great indication how
dangerous
white attack is even though black tried
to decline this gambit
that's it guys i hope with this lecture
now you are confident enough to play
this gambit over the board
you can literally use this as a complete
surprise weapon in the tournament
practice
and as i have shown in this video
white has not only lot of attacking
potential
but there are some cool tricks and traps
exist
which your opponent has to deal with
hate
all the time during the cave
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care